un immeuble menace de s'effondrer sauve
qui peut dans les rues de la ville de
yokohama
les images font froid dans le dos 11
mars 2011
il ya tout juste dix ans la terre
tremblait au japon le pays est frappé
par un séisme de 9,1 sur l'échelle de
richter
c'est le plus puissant jamais enregistré
dans l'archipel nippon et s'étendit
comprends pas j'ai jamais connu un
tremblement si fort deux minutes de
terreur suivi d'un tsunami
des vagues ravagent le nord-est du japon
parfois haute de plus de 20 mètres des
maisons des immeubles des voitures ainsi
que leurs occupants
tout est emporté les infrastructures du
nord du pays ont été submergés par la
vague des villes entières sont rasés à
l'image de sendai sur la côte japonaise
certains habitants tentent désespérément
de retrouver leurs proches
il n'y a que de la voiture dans laquelle
mon mari est en cas de fuir devant le
tsunami a été découverte là bas les
secouristes ont retrouvé qu'un blouson à
l'intérieur c'est le sien les vitres
étaient brisées la vague a dû emporter
mon mari en lapin corps retrouvé le dos
au lendemain de la catastrophe
la situation se détériore encore plus le
tsunami provoqué l'explosion d'une
partie de la centrale nucléaire de
fukushima située au nord-est de tokyo
une caméra de surveillance a capté cette
image saisissante
l'explosion du cube qui abrite le
réacteur numéro 1 de la centrale
14 mars 2011 nouvelle explosion d'un
réacteur suivie d'un incendie
les autorités japonaises se veulent
rassurantes mais la menace radioactive
pèsent sur la région
un périmètre de sécurité est installé
les japonais sont confinés chez eux
des dizaines de milliers d'entre eux
sont évacués de la zone je me sens
vraiment très mal la situation est très
complexe je ne sais plus comment prendre
les bonnes décisions
je suis complètement perdue même
sentiment d'incertitude chez sept
expatriés français installés dans la
région de fukushima
mais trois jours que j'envisage ne
partirai que je suis et je suis encore
là bien qu'il aime
j'ai eu ma fille ma famille en france
[Musique]
de fuir le choix le bilan est lourd la
catastrophe de fukushima a provoqué une
pollution radioactive dans l'air et dans
la mer encore présente aujourd'hui
quant au tsunami il a causé la mort de
plus de 19 mille personnes
[Musique]